[Music]
a given pipe is being designed to Flow
full with velocities within the range of
0.9 to 7 ft per second if the pipe is
expected to transport
0.05 to 0.4 million gallons per day of
flow what is the diameter of the pipe in
inches so this problem notes that the
sewer is Flowing full we should assume
that the max flow will be associated
with the max
velocity and that the Min flow is
associated with the minimum velocity
since the diameter of the sewer cannot
change solving for area using any other
combination of flow and velocity will
result in at least one of the cases
exceeding the flow and velocity
requirements specified so let's get
started
first we can convert our Max flow and
Min flow from million gallons per day to
CFS so we have Min Q
equals
0.05
MGD
times
million gallons over 1
mg
Time 1 day over 24
hours Time 1 hour over 60
Minutes times 1 cubic foot over
7.48 gallons and you can look this up in
the unit conversion section of the
reference manual if you need
to and solving out for this will give us
just about
0.077 ft cubed per
second next we can do the same thing for
the max
Q so that
is
0.4
MGD times same thing as above so if we
were to multiply all of this out for
this down here
we would
get
0.619 cubic feet per
second so now that we have our flow
rates in cubic feet per second our Max
and our Min flow we can divide the max
Flow by the max velocity and the Min
Flow by the Min velocity velocity this
will allow us to solve for the diameter
of the sewer in each of these
conditions so step
two Q Min
over V
Min equal a
equal
0.077 fet cub
per
second divided by the minimum is
0.9 feet per
second this will give us
0.0
85 ft
squared that's going to be equal to the
area equation of pi d^2 over
4 and D is going to be equal
to
0.33
ft multiply by 12 in to 1
foot gives you 4
in if we do the same thing here Q Max
over
Vmax = a =
[Music]
619 fet cubed per second over 7 feet per
second we will get
0.088 fet squared
same thing solved for the
[Music]
diameter and D here is going to be equal
also
to
about 0.33
ft AKA 4
in so that's all it takes to solve this
particular problem um the most important
part I think is identifying the fact
that
the Min flow and the Min velocity go
together as well as the max flow and the
max velocity since the diameter pipe is
going to be constant other than that you
just need to know how
to use Q equals VA which is pretty basic
and know how to use your unit
conversions and that's
it